plus de dix mille mètres carrés bientôt
100% dédié à la formation vie de ses
élèves partis étudier dans le nouveau
collège du val fourré l'établissement se
tourner vers la formation
professionnelle
principalement pour les décrocheurs
scolaires les bénéficiaires du rsa et
les deux demandeurs d'emploi nous sommes
tous convaincus que par l'éducation mais
par la formation nous pourrons vaincre
l'exclusion et le chômage de masse des
jeunes issus des quartiers petit globe
il ya un devoir des institutions de
proposer aux jeunes des solutions qui
leur soient adaptés il ya différentes
formes d'intelligence il ya des
intelligences conceptuel et des
intelligences plus pratique nous
travaillons sur toutes ces intelligences
un projet développé aussi grâce à un
partenariat avec la chambre des métiers
de l'artisanat des yvelines pour
développer une offre dans le nord du
département une formation coiffure a
débuté à la rentrée 2021 en septembre
2024 autres secteurs vont être proposés
nous avons à la chambre de métiers de
versailles à un cfa qui tombe déjà 700 à
750 jeunes et le président bédié nous a
fait une proposition ici qui nous a dit
montée - cf avait un montage au lit on a
réfléchi quand je vous le disais 25% des
jeunes vient de montage au lit pour les
à versailles pas forcément simple nous
avons des maîtres d'apprentissage et
nous avons des professeurs qui peuvent
venir ici aussi des associations vont
aussi progressivement prendre place dans
le site pour qu'il devienne un lieu à
part entière dans le quartier budget
pour la mise aux normes du site 1
million 8